c'est électroniques contiennent des
substances dangereuses pour la santé et
l'environnement il recèle aussi des
métaux précieux qui sont un atout
économique pour l'industrie du recyclage
c'est pour cette raison que
polytechnique montréal a mis sur pied un
programme pancanadien de recherche et de
formation en électronique et en éco
conception durable
on va en parler avec notre invité on l'a
rejoint en italie c'est celle qui pilote
le projet clara centre tente au
professeur au département de génie
physique et de polytechnique montréal
experts de l'électronique organique
merci d'être là madame saputo
merci a vous de me recevoir et expliquez
nous d'abord en quelques mots pourquoi
vous avez démarré ce projet là parce
qu'ils donc ça fait des primes
je dirais même temps que je m'occupe de
matériaux pour l'électronique des
dispositifs et aussi des dispositifs
organique c'est-à-dire là où les emmy
conducteurs sont à base donc des carbone
est donc en ligne en voyage on se rend
compte que les problèmes des déchets
électroniques existe en utilisant
l'aspect donc organique à des
semi-conducteurs avec lesquels je
travaille j'ai pensé donc à pouvoir si
vous voulez atténuer les problèmes des
l'accumulation des déchets par des
approches par exemple d'électronique
biodégradable mais donc des monts groupe
des recherches j'ai quand même voulu
avoir une approche vraiment beaucoup
plus holistique beaucoup plus complet
donc on a quand même à nous décider
ensemble c'est une team en équipe de
l'ambiance en cause un chercheur donc
d'attaquer le problème des déchets le
recyclage l'amélioration des pratiques
courantes et après avec un peu des
visions sur le long terme d'électronique
biodégradable à vous vous lavez et
fleuri ce phénomène il ya une
augmentation rapide du nombre de déchets
électroniques comment on explique sa
basse et si vous voulez celles évoquées
on a
clément de tout le monde qui peut se le
permettre on va en tout cas un accès à
l'électronique de consommation un
téléphone portable les tablettes des
ordinateurs portables
donc ça fait partie vraiment des notre
vie de tous les jours et ça ça induit
donc si vous voulez donc une
augmentation des dispositifs qui sont
disponibles mais aussi des dispositifs
comme est à près des côtes et sans trop
se préoccuper justement de leur fin de
vie
ouais c'est ça sincèrement il ya
l'aspect de l'obsolescence programmée
c'est en partie responsable du problème
selon vous je les crois profondément
donc c'est pour cela qu'on s'est posé
problème pas seulement donc de la
récupération du recyclage d'améliorer
les pratiques des mais aussi donc à
défaire des l'éco-conception comme en
revers a vraiment la conception de ces
dispositifs d'une façon qui sauf une qui
soit plus réparable
lors donc des petits dégâts aucun ne
veut simplement améliorer les
performances on pourrait décider donc de
faire une amélioration accommodante a
juste en changeant complètement dans les
dispositifs donc l'objectif de votre
programme madame sainte atos et c'est de
former les ingénieurs de de former les
experts qui sauront gérer ces
électronique de demain oui et je dirais
même encore plus large que ça c'est à
dire en de vraiment transmettre les
peler les valeurs des durabilité en
général à tous les technologies
émergentes c'est comme si on a un peu
l'addition des dé former des ingénieurs
qui considère la performance du
dispositif et la performance en termes
d'environnement et de santé humaine sur
le même plan donc lyon cherche
effectivement d'avoir un bilan très
délicat en inconscient mais on pense que
c'est une valeur absolument on ne peut
pas les manquer quand la formation de
nos ingénieurs
absolument il est clair que l'aspect
environnemental de ce projet là il est
évident mais il ya aussi un aspect
économique on en parlait tout à l'heure
il y a une valeur ces matériaux parfois
rare qu'on retrouve dans
des fresques doit être rentable de
recycler donc les déchets électroniques
alors c'est une question qui est très
intéressante donc comme a souvent comme
souvent la la rentabilité peut dépendre
aussi d'alister l'échelle d'un processus
c'est sûr que en principe si on pense
aux métaux précieux qui sont des déchets
électroniques et encore par exemple la
présence d'un des mines et rail d'or
on dirait c'est absolument rentable en
ci de travailler sur la récupération sur
la purification sur les récits plage de
ces métaux qui ont entre autres dans le
sens des métaux précieux
bien sûr donc moi j'encouragerai dans
les six ans à venir on encouragera
vraiment l'esprit d'entrepreneuriat de
nos étudiants mais qui sont aussi
risquent aussi d'être carrément des
éléments critiques des éléments en voie
de disparition et donc à la limite on à
la nécessité d'attaquer ces problèmes
ans et plus juste une question d'opinion
ou deux points de vue c'est un objectif
à long terme tout de même parce que pour
l'instant on est loin d'avoir les
infrastructures nécessaires en ce moment
là pour recycler pour réutiliser ces
déchets électroniques
je dirais qu'il ya quand même des
campagnes qui sont les gens qui font
dans ce type de business c'est clair qui
a de la marge d'amélioration pour voir
quel type à des processus si c'est
plutôt hydrométallurgique kir
métallurgique biomatériaux logique donc
c'est clair que nous sommes en plus tôt
à l'état donc des recherches mais il ya
des compagnies qui sont déjà pas mal a
établi nous avons sur les campus donc
une table par exemple qui s'occupe
carrément donc des traitement et
recyclage des déchets électroniques et
qui supporte les programmes très
fortement parce qu'en ce moment qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ces déchets donc les
déchets peuvent être enfouis les déchets
peuvent être une très petite fraction si
vous me permettez donc réparé et rémy
d'entre les marchés en vous et comme je
le disais souvent aussi
déplacer donc il sait il ya des seconds
faudrait carrément appelé donc un trafic
illégal de déchets électroniques par
exemple vers des pays de l'afrique
subsaharienne
ça c'est une autre volet de notre
programme on s'occupera fait ça on vous
souhaite bonne chance pour votre projet
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là madame
fanta tôt merci beaucoup à vous